Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. Now today we're once again joined by a friend of the show, Professor Andrew Preston of the University of Cambridge. Yesterday we were talking about American Crusades, about the Puritans, about the War of Independence, the Civil War, the Spanish-American War and so on. And today we're moving on into the 20th century, Spanish-American War, and so on. And today, we're moving on into the 20th century, what some people have called, of course, the American century. And we're going to be talking about America's relationship with religion, both at home and
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天，我们的节目再次迎来了老朋友——剑桥大学的安德鲁·普雷斯顿教授。昨天我们探讨了美国的十字军东征、清教徒、独立战争、内战、美西战争等等。今天，我们将步入20世纪，也就是有些人所称的“美国世纪”。我们将探讨美国与宗教的关系，无论是在国内还是
abroad. So we're going to be talking about American exceptionalism, we're going to be talking about the Cold War, Nixon, Reagan, Bush, Donald Trump, of course. But first of all, let's jump right back to the First World War. All the combatants in the First World War invoke God a lot, and religion plays a huge part in mobilizing their home populations. That's less true in Britain and France, let's say, in the Second World War, but it's still very true of the United States. So would you say the first, I mean, this is a massive question, obviously, it's a classic question that Europeans ask about America. Is it pretty much the first half of the 20th century, would you say, where you start to see a divergence between the United States and Western Europe? And if that's the case, or whenever it is, I mean, it's such a massive question. I'm
在国外。因此，我们将讨论美国的特殊论（American exceptionalism）、冷战、尼克松、里根、布什，当然还有唐纳德·特朗普。但首先，让我们直接回到第一次世界大战。一战中的所有参战国都频繁呼吁上帝，宗教在动员国内民众方面发挥了巨大作用。可以说，在二战中，英国和法国的情况并非如此，但这对于美国而言仍然非常真实。那么你会不会说，第一——我的意思是，这是一个非常宏大的问题，显然，这是欧洲人对美国的经典提问——你认为，大约是在20世纪的上半叶，美国与西欧开始出现分歧吗？如果是这样的话，或者无论何时开始——我的意思是，这是一个如此宏大的问题。我
embarrassed to be asking it. Why? Why are Americans still so much more religious, overtly religious, and much more comfortable? Yeah, overtly. Okay, fine, Tom. But even Tom, who thinks that everybody is still a Christian, would have to agree that Americans are overtly far more religious than their British, Danish, Belgian, Dutch, French counterparts. I mean, it's a massive question, but why? It's very much still a part of the American political culture in a way that isn't in some other countries. So I'm not sure that it necessarily changes in that period, although that is where the US begins to diverge from Western Europe. But I think the reasons for that go deeper. If we think about American
问这个问题都觉得有点不好意思。为什么？为什么美国人依然如此笃信宗教、表现得如此直白地笃信宗教，而且对此感到更加自在？是的，直白地。好吧，没问题，汤姆。但即使是认为每个人都依然是基督徒的汤姆，也不得不承认，与他们的英国、丹麦、比利时、荷兰和法国同行相比，美国人在表面上要宗教化得多。我的意思是，这是一个宏大的问题，但为什么呢？宗教在很大程度上仍然是美国政治文化的一部分，而在其他一些国家则不然。所以我不确定它是否一定在那段时期发生了变化，尽管那确实是美国开始与西欧分歧的起点。但我认为其中的原因更为深远。如果我们思考美国的
exceptionalism, why is America, you know, American exceptionalism means America is exceptional in two ways. One, that it's different from other countries. And the other way is that it's better. So it's exceptionally, it's exceptional in that it's different or it's exceptional in that it's better. And sometimes, especially to Americans, the sense that America is better, better, excuse me, slip of the Freudian slip of the tongue, that it's better stems from this sense of American difference, that it's somehow unique in the world. And religion is very much a part of that.
特殊论，为什么美国——你知道的，美国的特殊论意味着美国在两个方面是特殊的。第一，它与其他国家不同。第二，它是更好的。所以它是特殊的，因为它不同；或者它是特殊的，因为它更好。有时，特别是对美国人而言，美国更好、更好——抱歉，口误，弗洛伊德式口误——更好这种感觉，源于美国与众不同的意识，即它在世界上某种程度上是独一无二的。而宗教正是其中的重要组成部分。
It's always been. And when social scientists were asked and who predicted social scientists who predicted that as the world becomes more modern, it will become less religious, that that's the iron law of development. Modernization sort of crushes religion before it. And they were always asked, the social scientists were always asked, well, what about the United States? Because it's the most modern society in the world or one of the most modern societies. And yet not only is religion not dying, it actually seems to be increasing so that you get to the middle of the 20th century and America's in the midst of another great awakening, extremely religious 1950s. And so why is that? And I think a lot of that is
一直以来都是如此。当社会科学家被问到——那些预测随着世界变得越来越现代，世界就会变得越来越不宗教的社会科学家，他们认为这是发展的铁律。现代化在其面前某种程度上粉碎了宗教。人们总是问他们，社会科学家总是被问到，那么美国呢？因为它世界上最现代的社会之一，或者说最现代的社会之一。然而，不仅宗教没有消亡，它实际上似乎还在增长，以至于到了20世纪中期，美国正处于又一次宗教大觉醒的浪潮之中，这是一个极度笃信宗教的20世纪50年代。那么这是为什么呢？我认为这其中很大一部分
embedded much earlier in American political culture through things like the separation of church and state, which means that when the state is discredited, as it is in a lot of countries where there is no separation of church and state, like Russia or Mexico or France or elsewhere, when there's a revolution against the political authorities, there's then not a revolution against the church either. And the church isn't discredited along with politics, because politicians are always discredited. There's almost no anti-clericalism in American history. And that is, I don't want to say unique, because somebody always pops up with an exception, but it's very, very, very unusual. And I think it's very unusual had to compete. And so it gave rise to what sociologists call the marketplace of faith, which is a quintessentially American metaphor. The marketplace of faith where there has to be constant competition and innovation.
在很早的时候就已经根植于美国的政治文化中了，通过诸如此类的方式，比如政教分离。这意味着当国家失去信誉时——正如在许多没有政教分离的国家那样，比如俄罗斯、墨西哥、法国或其他地方，当发生反对政治当局的革命时，随之而来的并非是对教会的革命。教会并没有随着政治一同失去信誉，因为政客们总是会失去信誉。在美国历史上几乎没有反教权主义。我不愿意说这是独一无二的，因为总会有人举出反例，但这是非常、非常、非常罕见的。我认为这种罕见使得它不得不竞争。因此，它催生了社会学家所称的“信仰市场”，这是一个极其典型的美国隐喻。信仰市场要求必须进行不断的竞争和创新。
And so not only are the sort of long established churches, your Methodists, your Baptists, your Episcopalians, your Catholic, a little bit true within Catholicism as well. Not only are they competing with each other for adherence, you also have new faiths spring up through the 19th and early 20th centuries as a process or as a product, rather, of that process of competition. So you have the invention of new religions throughout this whole period in Mormonism and Seventh-day Adventism and the Nation of Islam and Reform Judaism, which began in Europe, but isn't really, doesn't become a big thing until the US. Well, so Andrew, just to ask about the Jews, because they become a very influential part
因此，不仅是那些历史悠久的教会——你的卫理公会派、浸信会派、圣公会派、天主教派（在天主教内部也有一点这种倾向），不仅是它们为了追随者而相互竞争，随着19世纪和20世纪初竞争过程的发展或产物，你还会看到新的信仰涌现出来。因此，在整个这一时期，你看到了新宗教的发明，比如摩门教、基督复临安息日会、伊斯兰民族组织（Nation of Islam），以及在欧洲兴起但直到在美国才真正成气候的改革派犹太教。好吧，那么安德鲁，就犹太人而言，因为他们成为了美国文化矩阵中非常具有影响力的部分，
of America's cultural matrix. How are they absorbed into the sense of America as a Christian nation? Well, they get it. It's a great question. They get absorbed through the invention of a tradition in the late 1930s, and that's the Judeo-Christian tradition. So Americans never before then talked about being Judeo-Christian, ever. And it's in the late 1930s because as Americans start realizing what's going on in Nazi Germany, as Franklin Roosevelt starts to try and position the US against Nazi Germany, he's looking for in Nazi Germany. As Franklin Roosevelt starts to try and
他们是如何被吸纳进美国作为基督教国家的观念中的呢？这是一个很好的问题。他们是在20世纪30年代末通过“发明传统”的方式被吸纳进来的，这个传统就是“犹太-基督教传统”（Judeo-Christian tradition）。在此之前，美国人从未谈论过什么“犹太-基督教”，从未有过。正是在20世纪30年代末，随着美国人开始意识到纳粹德国正在发生的事情，随着富兰克林·罗斯福开始试图将美国定位在对抗纳粹德国的立场上，他在纳粹德国寻找——随着富兰克林·罗斯福开始试图
position the US against Nazi Germany, he's looking for reasons to do so. And he starts emphasizing, at a time when a lot of other people aren't acknowledging what's going on, how Germans are treating Jews in Europe. This is before the war. This is before 1939. And FDR is starting to invoke a Judeo-Christian heritage. And that's what separates. Religious tolerance, religious pluralism, being a people of the book, that sort of thing, is what makes us Americans, as opposed to what's going on in Nazi Germany.
将美国定位在对抗纳粹德国的立场上，他在寻找这样做的理由。并在许多其他人还没有正视欧洲犹太人遭受德国人虐待的时候，他开始强调这一点。这是在战争爆发前，是在1939年之前。罗斯福总统开始呼吁建立一种犹太-基督教的传承。而这正是区分我们的所在。宗教宽容、宗教多元主义、作为一个“书本之民”（people of the book）等等，这些正是让我们成为美国人的原因，而不是纳粹德国正在发生的事情。
And that's what makes the Nazis our enemy. So he begins to sort of pound away at this message. It really catches on in World War II. And you have all sorts of wartime propaganda posters about catholics and protestants and jews fighting alongside each other that it doesn't matter what faith you are in the foxhole that you know we're all part of the same cause it just matters all that matters is whether you're an american and whether you're behind the cause and then of course you pivot very quickly from world War Two to the Cold War, where you're fighting an explicitly atheistic, anti-religious enemy. And that war isn't between
正是这一点让纳粹成为了我们的敌人。因此，他开始大肆宣传这一信息。它在二战中真正流行开来。你会看到各种各样的战时宣传海报，上面画着天主教徒、新教徒和犹太人并肩作战，上面写着你在散兵坑里信仰什么并不重要，你知道，我们都是为了同一个大义，唯一重要的是你是否是一个美国人，你是否支持这个大义。然后，当然，你从二战迅速转向冷战，在那里你要面对一个明确的、无神论的、反宗教的敌人。那场战争并非发生在
two nation states, but it's between two systems, two ways of life that's playing out on a global scale. And religion, but not necessarily Christianity, not even Protestantism, religion becomes embedded in American Cold War ideology. And that's what separates, that's what keeps us apart. And so the question, I mean, the question for a long embedded in American Cold War ideology. And that's what separates, that's what keeps us apart. And so the question, I mean, the question for a long time in American history was, you know, the important question is, are you a Protestant or are you a Catholic? And even it gets down to, are you a Methodist or a Baptist or an Episcopalian? And in the 20th century, the question then becomes not, are you a Protestant or a Catholic or a Jew? It's, are you religious or are you not
两个民族国家之间，而是发生在两个系统、两种生活方式之间，并在全球范围内展开。宗教——但不一定是基督教，甚至不是新教——宗教深深植入了美国的冷战意识形态中。这就是区分我们的地方，这就是让我们保持分歧的地方。因此，长期以来，美国历史上的问题——我的意思是，长期以来的重要问题是，你是新教徒还是天主教徒？甚至细化到，你是卫理公会派、浸信会派还是圣公会派？而在20世纪，这个问题不再是“你是新教徒、天主教徒还是犹太人”，而是“你是有宗教信仰的，还是没有
religious what you were saying andrew is is that um protestants and catholics and jews are being summoned i guess we could call it a crusade but certainly to an idea that their opponents are evil and the concepts of good and evil are obviously religious ones they're kind of bred of, let's call it Judeo-Christianity. So, you know, do you answer the summons to combat evil or do you not? And we have a question here from Harold Stassen. The US also has a long history of isolationism and suspicion of involvement with the outside world. Is this tradition in direct conflict with the history of American Crusades? I would guess you'd say not, because I guess you would say that there are also Christian motivations for not getting embroiled in foreign conflict. Absolutely. Exactly. The only thing I would quibble with with the question is the word
宗教信仰的？”安德鲁，你刚才所说的，是新教徒、天主教徒和犹太人正在被召唤——我想我们可以称之为一次十字军东征，但肯定是一种这样的观念：他们的对手是邪恶的，而善恶的概念显然是宗教概念，它们某种程度上孕育自——让我们称之为犹太-基督教。所以，你知道，你是否响应了打击邪恶的召唤？我们这里有一个来自哈罗德·斯塔森（Harold Stassen）的问题。美国也拥有悠久的孤立主义历史，并对卷入外部世界心存怀疑。这种传统与美国十字军东征的历史是否直接冲突？我猜你会说没有，因为你可能会说，不卷入外国冲突同样也有基督教动机。绝对是的。完全正确。我对这个问题唯一想挑剔的是“孤立主义”这个词，我不喜欢用它，因为我不认为美国曾经是一个孤立主义国家。如果你乘坐时间机器回到过去，如果你跳上你的德罗宁时间车，回到1860年或1890年，如果你告诉——我不知道，某个来自英国、古巴、墨西哥、加拿大、北非、中国或日本（在1850年代被美国强行打开国门）的人，如果你去世界上几乎任何地方，告诉他们美国是孤立主义的，他们自扫门前雪，不与世界其他地方交往，
isolationism, which I don't like using because I don't think the United States was ever an isolationist country. If you went back in a time machine, if you hopped in your DeLorean and went back to 1860 or 1890, and if you told, I don't know, somebody from Britain or Cuba or Mexico or Canada or North Africa or China or Japan, which is forcibly opened up by the United States in the 1850s, if you went almost anywhere in the world and you told them that Americans are isolationist and they keep to themselves and they don't engage with the rest of the world, You'd be lucky if they sort of, you know, shouted at you and said you were crazy. You'd probably get punched because most of those people I mentioned at one point or another were at war
你如果能听到他们对你大喊大叫说你疯了，那就算你走运了。你很可能会挨拳头，因为我刚才提到的绝大多数人，在某个时候都曾与美国交战，或者至少曾受到伤害——遭到过美国的攻击。所以美国从来都不是孤立主义的，但它确实对与其他国家的政治承诺、对其他国家的命运保持警惕。这种情况在20世纪发生了变化。但正如你所说，汤姆，这两种冲动——我写过一本关于宗教对美国战争与外交影响的书，书名叫《精神之剑，信仰之盾》（Sword of the Spirit, Shield of Faith）。这两者确实体现了美国十字军东征中的两种主要冲动：精神之剑，即那种好战的、具有侵略性的冲动；然后是信仰之盾，即那种更具和平主义色彩、改良主义色彩的冲动。但这二者都不是孤立主义的。
with the United States, or at least were injured, you know, had the United States attack them. So the U.S. has never been isolationist, but it has been wary of political commitments to other countries, to the f commitments to other countries, to the fates of other countries. And that changes in the 20th century. But as you said, Tom, both those impulses, the title of a book that I wrote on the religious influence on American war and diplomacy is called Sword of the Spirit, Shield of Faith. And those two things really speak to the two main impulses in the American Crusades, the sword of the spirit, the kind of warlike aggressive impulse, and then the shield of faith, the more pacifistic reformist impulse. But neither of them are isolationist.
那么让我们回到冷战，因为这显然是美国——你虽然不喜欢“孤立主义”这个词，但那是美国致力于其他国家、致力于其他国家命运的时期。是的，我同意，与之前的方式不同。它受制于北约。它致力于保卫西欧。由于宗教信仰的存在，冷战在美国是否有着不同的风貌？所以想想艾森豪威尔时期的美国，那种在公众心目中——我想说的是，那是一个小城镇居民向国旗宣誓效忠、高喊“我们信仰上帝”（In God we trust）的美国，在表面上极其笃信宗教，既有犹太-基督教传统，也有美国公民宗教。但这是否意味着，与其他西方国家相比，美国的冷战是不同的？所以在英国，很显然，
Let's go back then to the Cold War, because that's obviously the point at which America, you don't like the word isolationism, but that's when America is committed to other countries, to the fate of other countries. Yeah, I agree, in a different way than it was before. It's bound to NATO. It's bound to the defense of Western Europe. Does the Cold War have a different flavor in America because of the religiosity? So think about Eisenhower's America, the kind of, you know, in the public mind, I would say that's an America of sort of, you know, people in small towns pledging allegiance to the flag, in God we trust, very, very overtly religious, both the Judeo-Christian tradition and the American civil religion. But does that mean the Cold War is different in America from other Western countries? So in Britain, obviously,
冷战并没有那么宗教化。我的意思是，有一些有宗教信仰的人是……嗯，欧内斯特·贝文（Ernest Bevin）相当笃信宗教，但是，是的，但总的来说，公众变得远没有那么表面宗教化了，我认为，汤姆，我确实说过“表面上的”，而且……是的，我的意思是，你知道，在英国政治言论中，圣经引用几乎是极其罕见的，在冷战言论中也是如此，即使是撒切尔夫人——嗯，撒切尔，你知道，汤姆，她确实会这样做，这看起来很显眼，但她不如罗纳德·里根做得那么多。你知道，她对此有所克制，而且我认为她周围的人对此感到焦虑。
the Cold War is not really that religious. I mean, there are religious people who are... Well, Ernest Bevin was pretty religious but yeah but but by and large the public is becoming much less overtly religious i think tom i did say overtly um and um noted and uh yeah i mean you know sort of scriptural references are are vanishingly rare in british political rhetoric in cold in cold war rhetoric even mr thatcher well. Thatcher, you know, Tom, she does it, and it seems glaring, but she doesn't do it as much as Ronald Reagan does. You know, she polices it, and I think the people around her are anxious about it.
但这有助于将她塑造为一个冷战斗士，不是吗？是的，确实如此。确实如此，但她很罕见。我的意思是，你看，特德·希思（Ted Heath）可不会去引述圣经，并说我们致力于一场反对共产主义的十字军东征。我的意思是，他或哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）会说出这样的话，简直是滑稽可笑。但是安德鲁，所以出于这个原因，冷战在美国的感觉必然是不同的，对吧？嗯，我的意思是，你对英国历史的了解显然比我多。我不想——
But it helps to cast her as a Cold War warrior, doesn't it? Yeah, it does. It does, but she's unusual. I mean, look, Ted Heath is not kind of quoting the Bible and saying we're committed to a crusade against communism. I mean, the thought that he or Harold Wilson would say something like that is just laughable. But Andrew, so the Cold War must feel different in the United States for that reason, right? Well, I mean, you obviously know more about British history than I do. I don't want to.
我不是其他国家的历史学家，但我确实认为，仅根据我对冷战的了解，答案是肯定的，即美国与众不同，尤其是与西欧相比。这不仅仅是修辞。这不仅仅是对宗教价值观的修辞承诺。这不仅仅是为了证明那些出于其他目的而进行的政策是正当的，而使用宗教意象。它存在于成为美国人的核心意义之中。这并不是全部。这不是完整的故事。当然，并非每个人都有宗教信仰。但在20世纪40年代和50年代，一直延续到60年代和70年代（虽然程度稍减），但特别是在40年代和50年代，绝对是的。有宗教信仰，那就是美国的大义。这在很大程度上构成了美国在冷战中大义的重要部分。
I'm not an historian of other countries, but I do think just based on what I know of the Cold War, the answer is yes, that the United States is unusual, certainly compared to Western Europe. And it's not just rhetoric. It's not just a rhetorical commitment to religious values. It's not just sort of using religious imagery in order to justify policies that are really being conducted for other purposes. It's there at the heart of what it means to be an American. It's not the full picture. It's not the full story. And of course, not everyone was religious. But in the 1940s and 1950s, into the 60s and 70s, a little less so, but especially in the 40s and 50s. Absolutely. Being religious, that is America's cause. That's very much a big part of America's cause in the Cold War.
你通过富兰克林·罗斯福在二战中的政策看到了这一点，然后是通过哈里·杜鲁门和艾森豪威尔。在某个时刻，在冷战初期，随着冷战升温，杜鲁门希望召开一次由所有世界领导人参加的大型宗教峰会。他对他的助手们说——这是他用的语言。他说，你知道，联系教皇，联系坎特伯雷大主教，联系最高佛教徒、最高穆罕默德信徒和最高……这些都是极棒的备忘录，因为他只是希望所有世界宗教的巨头们都来到华盛顿特区。而他的助手们——他的一些助手有点摸不因脑头，因为这场战斗是针对无神论的。这场战斗是针对共产主义的，因为他们不信仰良知自由，他们不信仰宗教自由；如果他们不信仰良知或宗教自由，那么他们就无法信仰民主，这使得他们具有侵略性。然后，这是一个极好的故事，他要求他驻土耳其的大使去询问土耳其政府，谁是最高的穆斯林。还有什么有趣的？嗯，正如你所料，他说，
And you see it through the policies of Franklin Roosevelt in World War II, but then through Harry Truman and Eisenhower. And at one point, Truman wants, at the start of the Cold War, as the Cold War is heating up, he decides that he wants a big religious summit of all the world leaders. And he tells his aides, this is the language he uses. He says, you know, contact the Pope and contact the Archbishop of Canterbury and contact the top Buddhist and the top Mohammedan and the top. And these are wonderful memos because he just wants like the
“嗯，我们实际上不再有什么最高穆斯林了。”但事实上，大使先生——这是土耳其外交官对美国大使说的，“大使先生，难道贵国没有在宪法中确立政教分离吗？然而，你却把宗教作为你政策的基础。”好吧，我们在这里稍事休息。稍后我们再来讨论你的汤姆的问题。我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持
bigwigs of all the world religions to come to Washington, D.C. And his aides kind of, some of his aides kind of scratched their heads because the fight is against atheism. The fight is against communism because they don't believe in freedom of conscience they don't believe in freedom of religion and if they can't believe in conscience or or freedom of religion then they can't believe in democracy and that makes them aggressive and and then it takes this is wonderful story where he asks his ambassador to turkey to ask the turkish government who the top Muslim is. What else is good? Well, he says, as you'd expect, he says,
《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回来。现在，你已经准备好了。我们讨论了美国作为一个新教国家，我们也讨论了天主教徒和犹太人是如何被编织进其中的。但是冷战是否增强了这样一种感觉，即天主教徒和犹太人是新教的盟友？因为你刚才说过，给教皇打电话。尤其是约翰·保罗二世，我的意思是，他被里根、
well, we don't really have a top Muslim anymore. But actually, Mr. Ambassador, this is the Turkish diplomat saying this to the American ambassador, Mr. Ambassador, doesn't your country have enshrined a constitutional separation of church and state? And yet you're making religion the basis of your policy. Okay, let's take a quick break here. And we'll come back with your question, Tom. We'll see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host
撒切尔视为关键盟友。当然，二战后及整个冷战期间发生的另一件事，是以色列所扮演的角色、美国与以色列的联盟，以及美国福音派那种认为以色列的建立在某种程度上实现了上帝计划的感觉。那么这两者——你知道，冷战政策中的天主教和犹太维度，它们是否对国内不同宗教间的关系产生了反噬作用？是的，存在着持续的相互作用。我的意思是，杜鲁门当然也是承认以色列国的总统。他这样做是顶住了许多外交官的劝告，因为这会激怒阿拉伯世界。他引用了——我忘了你可能会知道，汤姆，但他引用了——他转向他的助手说，
The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back now, you were poised. We've talked about America as a Protestant nation, and we've talked about how Catholics and Jews kind of get woven into it. But does the Cold War enhance that sense that Catholics and Jews are allies of Protestantism? Because you said, get the Pope on the phone. John Paul II in particular, I mean he he's seen by reagan by
“我是释放犹太人的居鲁士（Cyrus）。”他的助手们根本不知道他在说什么，他的外交官们也是如此。因为在整个过程中，美国外交界其实并不是很宗教化。它是高度专业化的，是高度世俗化的。他们根本不知道他在说什么。但杜鲁门为自己成为第一个承认以色列国的领导人而感到非常自豪。所以他们确实参与进来了。这也是冷战的一部分。这不仅是对犹太人自由的承诺，也是为了对抗反宗教力量来弘扬宗教，因为反宗教的力量，
thatcher as a key ally and the other thing of course that happens after the second world war and through the cold war is the role that's played by israel and america's alliance with israel and the sense that evangelicals in america have that somehow the establishment of israel is a fulfillment of god's plan um and do those two you know know, the Catholic and the Jewish dimensions of Cold War policy, do they have blowback on domestic religious interfaith relations? Yeah, there's a constant interplay. I mean, Truman is, of course, also the president who recognizes the state of Israel. And he does so against the advice of a lot of his
同时也是侵略的力量、暴政的力量。这就是这一切如何最终被捆绑进美国冷战意识形态中的方式。当我们走到冷战结束时——显然里根是总统，里根显然是一个绝对、他是如此难以捉摸、如此模棱两可、如此迷人。他似乎极其不笃信宗教，带着一堆好莱坞式的黄色笑话，你知道，他离过婚，诸如此类。但是，而且在宗教方面也很难对他进行明确定义，不是吗？因为他相信鬼魂、占星术和各种古怪的东西。但他信仰邪恶。
diplomats, because it's going to enrage the Arab world. And he quotes, I forget what you'll probably know, Tom, but he quotes the, he says, he turns to his aides and he says, I am Cyrus, who freed the Jews. And his aides have no idea what he's talking about, his diplomats. Because throughout this process, the American diplomatic corps is actually not very religious. It's very professionalized. It's very secular. They have no idea what he's talking about. But Truman is very proud to be the first leader to recognize the state of Israel. So they do come in. And that's also part of the Cold War. That's part of sort of not just a commitment to the freedom of the Jews, but also to promoting religion against the forces of irreligion, because the forces of irreligion, because the
他也信仰上帝，他也信仰耶稣。他什么都信。但福音派运动某种程度上接纳了里根，或者说他们彼此接纳了对方——在冷战结束时，他们彼此接纳了。他们彼此接纳，从那个时间点开始，你认为——我的意思是，从20世纪80年代开始，是否存在一种语调上的转变，从而引出了乔治·W·布什的言论？还是说我把这视为某种断裂是错误的？因为显然此前卡特也非常笃信宗教。哦，是的。我的意思是，尼克松是个贵格会教徒。我不会说尼克松呼唤上帝的频率有多么惊人。
forces of irreligion are also the forces of aggression, the forces of tyranny. And that's how it all comes to be tied up in American Cold War ideology. When we get to the end of the Cold War, so obviously Reagan is president, and Reagan is obviously an absolutely, he's so elusive, he's so ambiguous, he's fascinating. He appears to be incredibly irreligious with his store of kind of Hollywood dirty stories and, you know, he's divorced and all this stuff. But, and he's also hard to pin down in religious terms, isn't he? Because he believes in ghosts and astrology and all kinds of wacky stuff. But he believes in evil.
嗯，尼克松是第一位开始在演讲结尾加上“上帝保佑美国”的总统。是吗？这很有趣。是的，是的，是的。但那纯粹是出于政治原因。我正要说的是，我的意思是，没有人比理查德·尼克松更能装出真诚的样子了。尽管他确实——你知道这个故事吗，多姆，他在“水门事件”期间要求基辛格跪下来和他一起祈祷。是的，我们知道了。我们在水门事件播客中涵盖了这一点。
He believes in God too, and he believes in Jesus. He believes in evil he believes in god too and he believes in jesus he believes in it all but the evangelical movement kind of adopts reagan or they adopt each other at the end of each other they adopt each other um they adopt each other and from that point do you think there is i mean is it fair to say there is a tonal shift from the 1980s onwards that leads to the rhetoric of george w Bush? Or am I wrong in seeing that as any kind of break? Because obviously Carter had previously been very religious. Oh, yeah. I mean, Nixon was a Quaker. He didn't invoke God an enormous amount, I wouldn't have said Nixon.
这是一个多么可怕的时刻，不是吗？因为他对——他和基辛格祈祷，然后他说：“亨利，无论你做什么，千万不要把这件事告诉任何人。不要急着发到推特上。”是的。然后他说，“亨利，无论你做什么，千万不要把这件事告诉任何人。别急着发到推特上。”是的。但是里根是一个断裂吗——在将福音派语言引入政治方面，还是说在总统政治中他只是复兴了它？好吧，他不是一个断裂，他复兴了它。而且他复兴的方式非常——让许多人感到大惊小怪，同时也是一种政治上非常娴熟的方式。你知道，当然，在一长段缓和期之后，他将苏联描述为一个“邪恶帝国”。对于许多人来说，他这样做非常
Well, Nixon is the first president to start signing off his speeches, God bless America. Is he? That's interesting. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But that was purely for political reasons. I was about to say, I mean, nobody does sincerity better than Richard Nixon. Although he does, you know this story, Dom, where he does ask during Watergate, he asks Kissinger to get on his knees and pray with him. Yeah, we did. We covered that in our Watergate podcast.
可怕，包括他自己的许多助手在内。但人们忘记了，他在全美福音派协会（National Association of Evangelicals）年度大会上发表了那次演讲，这是美国最具影响力的宗教组织，不仅在宗教上有影响力，在政治上尤其具有影响力。在经历了15年的缓和期之后，他选择在那个论坛上称苏联为“邪恶帝国”。宗教在很大程度上——那种宗教的、那种精神之剑，在很大程度上处于里根主义和里根的反共产主义的核心。但有趣的是，信仰之盾也是如此。因此，当里根在1984年实现转向，抛弃那种冷战斗士的言论，
Such a terrible moment, isn't it? Because he says to, he prays with Kissinger and then he says, Henry, whatever you do, don't tell anybody about this. Don't rush it out. Get some Twitter. Yeah. to and then he says um henry whatever you do don't tell anybody about this rushes out gets on twitter yeah but is reagan a break um in bringing evangelical language into politics or is it all is it in presidential politics he just revives it okay he he's not a break he revives it and he revives it in a very in a way that freaks a lot of people up and in a way that's also very politically skillful you know he of course i mean, he describes the Soviet Union as an evil empire after a period of daytime. And it's very
寻找摆脱冷战的出路、试图结束冷战时，他在米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫身上找到了合作伙伴，他们开始进行谈判。他也以一种更加微妙的方式，将宗教用作——既作为方法，也作为目标，试图寻找摆脱冷战的出路。所以在方法方面——我不会讲所有细节，但在70年代末，有一个五旬节派（Pentecostals）家庭，这是20世纪初发明的又一个美国宗教。五旬节派诞生于洛杉矶。因此，在西伯利亚有一群五旬节派教徒。他们被称为“西伯利亚七人组”。他们以宗教自由的名义，前往莫斯科的美国大使馆，一路旅行……却不让他们离开。当然，美国人也不让他们离开大使馆，因为谁知道会发生什么呢。这成了一个巨大的问题，在政治上是一件非常大的事情。里根在他更加好战的阶段经常谈到这件事，作为证据：这就是为什么他们是邪恶的，他们在剥夺人们的良知自由、民主、宗教以及所有诸如此类的事情。但在1983-1984年，当他在寻找出路时，他接触了苏联人并说，
scary to a lot of people that he does that, including to a lot of his own aides. But people forget that he gave that speech to the annual convention of the National Association of Evangelicals, the most powerful religious organization in the United States, not just religiously powerful, but especially politically powerful. And he chooses that forum to call the Soviet Union an evil empire after 15 years of detente. And religion is very much that kind of religious, that sort of sword of the spirit is very much at the heart of the Reagan doctrine and Reagan's anti-communism. But interestingly, also is the shield of faith. So when Reagan makes his pivot in 1984 away from that cold warrior rhetoric and
他说，我们可以悄悄地做这件事。如果你让他们离开这个国家并最终定居美国，我不会在政治上大做文章。他确实做到了。他信守承诺。这是美苏之间采取的第一个建立信任的措施，为缓和铺平了道路。后来，当他会见戈尔巴乔夫，他们乘坐直升机在雷克雅未克、维也纳等地的峰会上飞来飞去时，里根一直在向他唠叨。戈尔巴乔夫后来问：他到底为什么跟我说这些？
looks for a way out of the Cold War, looks to try and end the Cold War, and he finds a partner in Mikhail Gorbachev and they begin to negotiate. He also, in a much more subtle way, uses religion as a way to, as both method, but also objective in trying to more subtle way, uses religion as both method but also objective in trying to find a way out of the Cold War. So in terms of method, I won't go into all the details, but in the late 70s, there was a family of Pentecostals, another invented American religion in the early 20th century. Pentecostalism was born in Los Angeles. And so there's a group of Pentecostals in Siberia. They were called the Siberian Seven. And they, in the name of religious liberty, they went to the U.S. Embassy in Moscow, traveled all the way wouldn't let them leave. And of course, the Americans wouldn't let them out of the embassy because who knows what would happen to them. And it became a huge issue, a really big deal politically. And Reagan talked about it a lot in his more aggressive phase as an evidence, this is why they're evil and they're denying people the
因为我真的不在乎。但里根一直在向他唠叨。他说，他一直在向他唠叨宗教自由的重要性，以及个人在宗教之上的选择权的重要性，这是一个非常新教的概念。而且，他说，
freedom of conscience and democracy and religion and all that sort of thing. But in 1983-4, when he's looking for a way out, he approaches the Soviets and he says, he says, we can do this quietly. And if you if you let them leave the country and eventually settle in the United States, I won't make a big deal politically about it. And he does that. He's good to his word. And that's the first confidence building measure that the Americans and the Soviets do that paves the way for detente. And later on, when he meets Gorbachev and they're flying around in helicopters and summits in Reykjavik and Vienna and places like that, Reagan keeps lecturing to him. And Gorbachev later says, why on earth is he telling me this?
这就是你所需要的——而且，他说，如果你只是认识到这一点并拥抱它，那么它将带来更好的结果。所以这是一种对自由民主、美国公民宗教等诸如此类事物的论证。当冷战结束时，总结这一点的著名口号是弗朗西斯·福山（Francis Fukuyama）——一位新教牧师的儿子——所写的《历史的终结》。我实际上并不知道这一点。我实际上并不知道这一点。是的，所以福山绝对是出身于这种新教的、有趣的、对——你知道的——普遍性的理解之中。而且，本质上在我看来，他对历史终结的愿景是末世论的一种世俗化愿景。你知道，自由民主的普世价值已经蔓延开来。所以，美国随后走出来——这就是美国将自己塑造成为什么的捍卫者。从某种意义上说，你可以说，自冷战以来，在某种程度上，美国一直忠于其作为正义捍卫者、而非邪恶对抗者的自我认知。我想，如果你谈论的是犹太-基督教文明，臭名昭著的是“9·11”及其余波，这就开始与另一大书本宗教——伊斯兰教产生摩擦。步入21世纪，你如何看待这作为美国将自己视为十字军的一种困境？事实上，关于我们从“疯狂的索纳托”（Captain Insano）那里收到的这个问题：你认为小布什在反恐战争中关于“十字军东征”的评论是一个口误，反映了美国外交政策中现有的思想和态度吗？对于最后一个问题？绝对是的。是的，我认为这是一个真正的口误。我认为他完全不知道历史背景以及那将在世界其他地方引起的回响，但我认为使用这个词绝对——好吧，我只是在同意这个问题。是的，它绝对反映了这样一个事实：他伸手去够那个词，他伸手去够那个——他甚至不用去够，它就在那里。仅仅因为它碰巧在那里，因为他沉浸在那样的——是的，在这个意义上，我不认为这是蓄意的，我不会说不，完全是这样，是的，完全是这样。但是，那么——乔治·H·W·布什显然他甚至——他是一个福音派信徒，他习惯于新教福音派的语言，那是他在“9·11”之后所触及的东西。所以你拥有美国外交政策中的那种倾向，这种倾向贯穿了整个21世纪初。然后你还有另一种共和党人的倾向，非常不同，那就是以唐纳德·特朗普为代表的“美国优先”的那种倾向。
Cause I really don't care. But Reagan keeps lecturing to him. He says, he keeps lecturing to him about the importance of religious freedom and the importance of individual choice over religion, which is a very Protestant notion. And, and he says,
那么特朗普的那种倾向，你认为那是——我的意思是，那看起来与我们一直在讨论的那么多内容如此不同，因为这其中甚至还有任何宗教成分吗？他被比作居鲁士，不是吗？他是的，完全是，是的，是的，这也是其中的一部分。但在那之前——乔治·W·布什，还有另一个——是的，他有福音派那种十字军东征式的言论，他有——然后还有其他的支流，我忘了是什么，但你提到了其他一些支流。然后还有——他也明确地调用了那种多元主义的传统，即宗教多元主义的传统，可以追溯到富兰克林·罗斯福、哈里·杜鲁门和其他人，这种传统据说是多元主义的，但它的核心是一个新教的核心。基地组织并不代表真正的伊斯兰教。他们不是真正的穆斯林。他还说，前进的道路是通过宗教宽容和宗教多元主义。这也是奥巴马延续的信息。
this is what you, and this, and he says, if you just recognize this and embrace it, then it will lead to better things. So that's a kind of argument for liberal democracy, American civil religion, all that kind of thing. When the Cold War ends, the famous slogan that sums it up is the end of of history written by francis fukuyama who is the son of a protestant minister i actually didn't know that i actually didn't know that yeah so so so fukuyama is absolutely from this kind of protestant interesting uh universal understanding of of you know and essentially it seems to me that his vision of the end of history is a kind of secularized vision of the end times. It's, you know, the universal values of liberal democracy have spread. So, and America then comes, that's what America comes to cast itself as the defender
他最著名的外交政策演讲是2009年6月在开罗的演讲。他说，中东饱受折磨，它被卷入了强国竞争，战争孕育着战争。出路是什么？他说，宗教宽容、宗教多元主义，因为没有这些，你就无法拥有和平；没有和平，你就无法拥有稳定和民主。如果你基本上——你必须拥有宗教宽容和宗教多元主义，这是我们在美国传统中长期拥有的东西。所以不仅是乔治·W·布什在说这样的话。但是特朗普呢？特朗普不同吗？
of. So in a sense, you could say that since the Cold War, to that degree, America has remained true to that idea of itself as a defender of what is good, as opposed to what is evil. And I suppose that if you're talking about Judeo-Christian civilization, notoriously with 9-11 and its aftermath, that then starts to rub up against the other great religion of the book, which is Islam. And going into the 21st century, how do you see that as a kind of a problem for America's sense of itself as a crusader? In fact, I mean, absolutely on that question we have from Captain Insano, do you think George Bush's crusade comment around the war on terror was a slip of the tongue that reflected existing thoughts and attitudes to US foreign policy? To that last question? Absolutely. Yes, I think it was a genuine slip of the tongue. I think he had no clue about the historical context and resonance that that would
不，我的意思是，正如汤姆所说，他——你知道，所以他拥有这一面，他非常、非常亲以色列，他在很大程度上亲以色列，因为那是他政治基本盘的很大一部分。白人福音派投票给特朗普的人数和比例，甚至比他们投票给乔治·W·布什或罗纳德·里根时还要高得多。特朗普本人非常、非常不笃信宗教。但正如你所说，多姆，你不必在个人信仰上很宗教，就能获得宗教右翼或任何宗教社群的支持。所以他并不宗教，但他说了所有正确的话。他做了所有正确的事情。我想他说过——谈到《圣经》时——它甚至比《交易的艺术》（The Art of the Deal）还要好。
have in other parts of the world but i think the use of the word absolutely well i'm just agreeing with the question yes it absolutely reflected the fact that he reaches for that word he reaches for that he doesn't even reach for it it's just there he just the fact that it's accidentally there because he's steeped in that kind of yeah in that sense i don't think it's deliberate i wouldn't say no exactly yeah yeah exactly but what about so george shibli bush obviously he's even he's an evangelical he's comfortable with the language of um of protestant evangelicalism and that's what he reaches for after 9-11 and so you have that sort of tendency in american foreign policy which is there throughout the early 21st century. And then you have also Republican, very different, the America first kind of tendency of epitomized by Donald Trump.
是的，没错。他显然从未读过它。嗯，有两本书他从未读过，因为他甚至没有亲自写过《交易的艺术》。他连那本书也没读过。《交易的艺术》。当他在“黑人的命也是命”抗议期间走到白宫对面的教堂时，他在教堂前面举起了一本《圣经》，
And is the Trump sort of tendency, do you think that is, I mean, that seems so different from so much of what we've been talking about, because is there any religious components of that at all? He's compared to Cyrus, isn't he he is yeah exactly yeah yeah and that's part of it but just on the before that george toby bush there's another yes he he has the evangelical sort of crusading rhetoric um and he has and then the other strands i forget what they were but you mentioned some other strands but then there's also he also explicitly invokes that that tradition of pluralism, of religious pluralism that goes back to Franklin Roosevelt and to Harry Truman and others that is supposedly pluralistic, but has at its heart a Protestant core, Al-Qaeda does not represent true Islam. They're not true Muslims. And he also says that the way forward here is through religious tolerance and religious pluralism. And it's a message that Obama continues.
他把它倒拿了一会儿。是的，他不是一个有信仰的人。但在20世纪50年代，他与诺曼·文森特·皮尔（Norman Vincent Peale）牧师关系密切，我相信皮尔曾为他的第一场婚礼主婚。皮尔是20世纪50年代那些自助书的作者。它们叫什么来着？“耶稣希望你变富”那种书。
His most famous foreign policy speech, the address in Cairo in June of 2009. He says the Middle East is wracked by, and it sucks in great power competition, and war begets war. What's the way out of this? And he says, religious tolerance, religious pluralism, because without that, you can't have peace. And without peace, you can't have stability and democracy. And if you basically, you have to have religious tolerance and religious pluralism, which is something we've had for a long time in the American tradition. So it's not just George W. Bush who's saying that sort of thing. But what about Trump? Is Trump different?
不，但某种程度上是世俗化的宗教。《积极思考的力量》（The Power of Positive Thinking）。那是诺曼·文森特·皮尔和所有那些书。特朗普也非常相信这些。所以这并不是真正的宗教，但是——回到汤姆在播客开始时提出的一个问题或陈述，如果它浸透了一切，它什么时候才不再被称为宗教？它永远不会。
No, I mean, as Tom said, he's, you know, so he's got the one, he's very, very pro-Israel, and he's in large part he's pro-Israel because that's a big part of his political base. White evangelicals vote for Trump in much greater numbers and a greater proportion of their numbers than they did even for George W. Bush or Ronald Reagan. Trump himself is very, very irreligious. But as you said, Dom, you don't have to be personally religious to have support from the religious right or any religious community. So he's not religious, but he says all the right things. He does all the right things. I think he says that, talking about the Bible, that it's even better than the art of the deal.
它永远不会。这是一个完美的结束语。只是在鼓励汤姆，这可不是什么好消息。不，安德鲁，非常明智，非常明智。顺便说一句，这是一本非常棒的书，《精神之剑，信仰之盾》。它还获奖了，对吧？
Yeah, that's right. He's obviously never read it. Well, two books he's never read because he didn't even write art of the deal. He never read that either. The art of the deal. When he marches over to the church across from the White House during the Black Lives Matter protests, and he's holding up a Bible in front of the church,
在你家乡加拿大？年度最佳图书。有史以来最优秀的加拿大著作。难道那个奖项不是类似于这样的吗？我想你和玛格丽特·阿特伍德（Margaret Atwood）是——那两位最顶级的加拿大人，还有罗伯逊·戴维斯（Robertson Davies），是的。好的，安德鲁，非常感谢你，也感谢所有收听节目的各位。我们下期《历史的余烬》再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要收听独家加更、抢先体验无广告节目并访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
he holds it upside down for a while. Yeah, he's not a man of faith. But he was close to Reverend Norman Vincent Peale in the 1950s, who I believe married, presided over his first marriage. And Peale was the author of, you know, those self-help books from the 1950s. What are they called? Jesus Wants You to Be Rich kind of books.
他把它倒拿了一会儿。是的，他不是一个有信仰的人。但在20th世纪50年代，他曾与诺曼·文森特·皮尔牧师关系密切，我相信皮尔主持了他的第一次婚礼。皮尔是20th世纪50年代那些自助书的作者，你知道的。它们叫什么来着？有点像是《耶稣想让你发财》那种书。
No, but religious but secularized in a way. The Power of Positive Thinking. That's Norman Vincent Peale and all of those books. And Trump very much believed in those too. So it's not really religious, but it's – to go back to a question Tom or a statement Tom made towards the beginning of the podcast, if it suffuses everything, when does it stop becoming religious? It never does.
不，但是宗教性的，但在某种程度上又世俗化了。《积极的力量》。那是诺曼·文森特·皮尔以及所有那些书。特朗普对这些也非常深信不疑。所以这并不是真正的宗教，但是——回到汤姆在播客开始时提出的一个问题或陈述，如果它弥漫在一切事物之中，它什么时候才不再具有宗教性？它永远不会。
It never does. That's a perfect note on which to end. Just encouraging Tom, which is not good to hear. No, Andrew, very wise, very wise. It's a brilliant book, by the way, Sword of the Spirit, Shield of Faith. And it won a prize, didn't it,
它永远不会。这是一个完美的结束语。只是在鼓励汤姆，这可不是什么好听的话。不，安德鲁，非常明智，非常明智。顺便说一句，这是一本杰出的书，《圣灵之剑，信仰之盾》。它得过奖，对吧，
in your Native Canada? Top book of the year. Best Canadian book ever written. Wasn't that the that the prize something like that i think you and margaret atwood are the uh the two top two top canadians and davies yeah right andrew thank you very much uh thank you for all of you uh for listening and we will see you next time on the rest is history goodbye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest isorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
在你祖国加拿大？年度最佳图书。写得最好的加拿大图书。奖项不是类似这样的吗？我想你和玛格丽特·阿特伍德是呃那两位顶尖的加拿大人，还有戴维斯，对吧，安德鲁，非常感谢你，呃感谢所有收听节目的朋友们，我们下期《历史的剩余部分》再见，再见，拜拜，感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》，想要收听额外单集、提前抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘闻》。这是您每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想收听无广告节目、获取额外单集以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。